[Music]
at least 78 people have died in a
stampede during a charity handout in
Yemen's Capital hundreds of people in
Sanaa had gathered to receive financial
assistance in food overcrowding though
then led to a crush to disperse the
crowd shots were fired which Witnesses
say hit a nearby generator causing an
explosion Muhammad al-atab reports from
Sana
this is a traffic incidence that
happened after eight or eight o'clock in
the ma at night people poor people got
together in the near these
distributions Center for Distributing
financial assistance for poor people
there were hundreds of people there
waiting for to receive their financial
assistance this this is uh really has
sparked a nationwide angry among people
as this incident is the first of its
kind to happen especially at the the
last 10 days of the holy month of
Ramadan and also ahead of the aid of
Althea according to the spokesperson of
the minister the interior Ministry he
said that the two measures have been
detained because of this incident uh the
the are calling on the merchants
in case they want to distribute their
financial assessments they should go to
the uh the the the government Ministry
and that which is the one who should
distribute assisted to people usually
emotions distribute by themselves as
they have they lack the trust of the
government they're by themselves mostly
they also divide the money between the
government and also for money that we
would like to distribute by themselves
in order to reach the poor people and
the the people who are in need so this
incident should uh would would require
would also put an end maybe for this
kind of uh distribution of Aid there are
around 17 million people who are in need
for assistance in Yemen because of the
because of the ongoing war on Yemen